good morning sorry I'm
late all
right uh altern
let's see represent hackin Phillips
could sit in for Senator chanle all
right and representative grassy can in
for
Senator
Whitley everyone else is a regular
member I
think all
right on the minutes of the previous
meeting any
uh do we have a motion to approve
any comments questions or
Corrections seeing none those in favor I
I was
opposed we have our
minutes Madam chair yes our stenographer
is ill today and could not be here so
it's will be very important and she's
going to use the video to do the
transcription so it'll be important for
all the witnesses to State their name
and fill out a pink card and uh let
everybody know who is making a motion in
second thank you
right is there anything to be removed
from the consent
agenda Madam chair yes uh nothing to be
removed but I just wanted to make a
comment on two of the items um so the
first item is 2023 1220 the board of
psychologist conditional approval
request um and then the one that follows
uh rule 2023 143 the conditional
approval request for the Board of
Professional
geologists uh my concern in reading
through the materials um was the
reminder that we had lengthy discussions
and several meetings but I I believe as
far back as July about the fees related
to these um requests and the possible
need for future legislation or
additional oplc rul making and um
because I know we spent a considerable
amount of time discussing those two um
issues in length I I think it's just
worthy of noting again for the record
that um this is an ongoing matter and
that the committee is familiar with
those discussions before we pass them
thank you I'd like to mention that um I
at least have submitted
legislation U clarifying the fee issue I
believe there may be others because
there's a whole lot of other bills
addressing oplc uh we haven't seen the
words yet but uh we they will be
considered when they get this
year anyone
else okay those in favor I oppos I
seeing none thank
you the board of Podiatry Madam chair
yes did we have a motion in second on
the consent yes moved by Senator Ward
and seconded by
represent I thought that was for the
minutes I believe it was representative
Schmidt yeah okay I thought that was for
the
minutes that was for the minutes you are
so correct I apologize do we have a
motion on the consent calendar Do It All
Over Again move to approve the consent
calendar and I'll second that okay move
by representative Schmidt seconded by
representative hacken Phillips any
further discussion
those in favor I
opposed
okay now the
pediatrist okay so Board of Podiatry um
initial applications education
requirements and
fees this item was postponed from the
last meeting and an amended conditional
approval request has been filed to
update the rule to say um oplc rather
than board um as the authority to
process the licensing applications I
believe this was a request of
Representative groda so the um the
proposal has been amended to address
that they've also addressed uh some of
the other comments that were made um at
the last meeting the committee wanted
more information on the collection of
fees while the rules have been expired
and so the board is supposed to have
that information today um a lot of the
rules have been expired since April of
2019 and the statute doesn't establish
the fees rather they're supposed to be
set up in rule if you recall the um the
PLC rules with the fees were just
recently adopted in July so there is
that time period from April of 2019 to
July of this year um in which you know
they may have collected some fees in
violation of 541
a22 which says that no expired rule can
be enforced for any purpose um anyway
that's the only issue really that
remains in The Proposal and like I said
the board is I'm supposed to be able to
speak to that today good
morning good morning Tina Kelly from the
office of professional licensure and
certification with regards to the
expired rules um to the extent they
would be enforced would would have been
through the rsas um 315 27 and8
specifically for parts of those um there
were no disciplinary actions I look back
in that nothing no disciplinary action
was Tak on any expired rule with regards
to the
fees um the fees were in statute until
71 of
2022 so the um the question is whether
or not fees were charged by 7even
between 71 of 22 and 81 of 23 and they
were
not I could I take it the board of
pediatry has a scheduled renewal event
has a what well that all the the
licenses expire at one point and they're
all processed then yes how
convenient
okay any other
questions no okay is there a motion I
move to approve
second okay move by representing br a
second by representative Lynn I believe
okay any further
discussion those in favor I
oppos thank you very
much okay um the watercraft safety rules
I believe we were going to postpone
those yes ma'am um so this item is to be
postponed as we are expecting a
conditional approval request to be filed
to address the um the many comments in
the proposal and um so the committee
will need a waiver of its deadline to
act in order to postpone this item all
right does someone wish to do that
representative moveed by representative
Schmidt second second by representative
hacken Phillips any
discussion all right seeing none those
in favor I
opposed all right they are
postponed uh bo Board of Nursing okay um
Board of Nursing licensing requirements
um there has been an an amended
conditional approval request filed and
the forms were also uh filed this week
um but there are still uh some
legislative in comments to
review the first one is going to be on
page five of the conditional approval
request packet which is um page one of
the rule text there's a comment there
because the rule rule allows for the
lure of lnas by comparable
education but that's not a category of
lure under the statute the statute um
talks about some other categories of
lure but doesn't mentioned um by
comparable
education so um in additionally it so it
looks like we're not really sure but it
looks like there isn't a category for
that in the statute one and then
secondly I'm not seeing anything the
rules that really outline what criteria
the board will use to make that
determination what comparable education
means the rule does have you know
requirements for documentation that has
to be submit submitted and and stuff
like that to substantively show that
there was some education but as far as
whether or not you know how that meets
you know approval how that is good
enough doesn't appear to be outlined in
the rule um the other comment is or
actually there you're going to see
throughout the proposal well let's
settle this issue first if you don't
mind sure M
re good morning again good morning Tina
Kelly with the office of professional
liur and
certification so as far as the
comparable education goes under RSA 326
under their rulemaking
Authority um ran numeral I it says
eligibility requirements for in for
issuance of initial license
um although it doesn't state it
specifically um
it's it it does provide the authority to
set those those
rules and as far as the
um uh I have a question on that why why
comparable what is comparable to you
already have alternate education
shouldn't this be something more like
necessary education or appropriate
education or something like that that it
would be comparable to what is already
in the rules because um there have been
instances where somebody from the past
has gotten the fund the core core hold
on let me find it the um fundamentals
course work and although it's not called
that so it's it's comparable to what the
board requires so it would be the same
thing only it may be called something
different and we can't because this this
application form looking at it
doesn't um they are required to to have
the
examination or have the examination or
education one or the
other if I'm reading it
correctly
um I'm not sure I'm going to have to
look at that more yeah because if
looking further down the page it says an
applicant by comparable education shall
submit the transcripts okay that's fine
by alternate
experience which
seems not listed as one other
criteria what do you mean alternate
experience yeah down on page three sub
paragraph F yeah seeking lur an LNA by
alternate experience shall in addition
to to B which is the
um
um the
application let
see yeah if I could just jump in yeah I
mean the statute talks about licensure
by endorsement and then by examination
and then by alternate experience
experience those seem to be the three
categories and and in my conversation
with Mike we just you know we made this
comment because it seemed like that you
know it didn't fall into one of those
three categories the alternate education
doesn't fall into one of those
categories either right it should be
alternate
experience right did I say educate sorry
alternate experience is one of the
categories so it's endorsement
examination and then alternate
experience so just not sure where where
this where comparable falls into those
three it looks like it doesn't I'm not
sure where alternate education Falls
either so it I mean I don't have any
doubts about the lnas but this this rule
doesn't make
sense pretty opaque
anyway it's pretty opaque anyway thank
you representative
sh Madame chair if we were to use use
language that we have we already that
already exists in statute that we it
would be more comparable I mean I it
would make more sense so I think
consistency in language
throughout the statutes
for um what we're talking about when
we're talking about
comparing
um experiences or education I think we
have to use the same language so that
it's always you know it's not in
question
yeah thank you I agree and I also think
that if you're talking about it in a
rule that the the header language ought
to agree with what's below because the
the header language says one of the
options is alternate
education and the details are for
alternate um
experience you're absolutely right I
didn't I didn't catch that thank you for
catching that Madam chair it says
alternate education it doesn't say
alternate experience you're correct we
can make that change that's that's
it should be alternate Ed is that
alternate education or alternate
experience experience okay
then
um so then that makes the other one
comparable
education which is education that
they've received that is comparable to
what is is initially outlined as the
requirements
um
um okay
required a license it doesn't so if
someone were to have worked in the field
for some time and just decide to take
the exam that's that's all they need to
do if they pass the
exam that's what the board is allowing
for yes okay thank you that's
clear anyone
else I have a question yes in in
statutes or in bills that we've seen
we've used the word substantially
similar have we eliminated that term now
for
comparable so that we should I mean the
statutes should reflect the same
language as the rules I would think well
in this case the education that it's
comparable to is not well defined right
so I I think
uh I think you could just delete
comparable
education it's the word the comparable
they can seek leny by passing the exam
by having education by having experience
or by
endorsement would that would that be
agreeable changing the changing the
applicant shall seek Lure
by you saying take out e Al together
or comparable Al together yeah taking
out just com because you define in that
subparagraph um you define what kind of
education they need to
have but nowhere else is there the
mention of the education that is
comparable to but you know here an
seeking lenser by education will show
shows their transcript their uh their
grades and so forth I mean that's that's
the education so what I would have to
look back and see in other parts of the
rules if there's a description of
education and if we were to say
comparable to that education as defined
in sure would solve the issue or just
leave it leave out the comparable here
because that's that looks like a pretty
I'm afraid I'm afraid to change well I
I'm not sure I'd have to ask the board
because this one is is this going to
affect what
they
originally asked for I'm gonna have to
bring this back to the board I'm not
sure what they're going to want to do
all
right so um M ree I was just going to
say you know the we could postpone this
to allow um Tina to to confer with the
board um if we do that the committee
will need a waiver of its um deadline if
from if I was understanding right it
looks like in that paragraph a um
chairwoman Maguire you were thinking to
remove comparable education and then
have it just say having received a
alternative alter alternate experience
or by endorsement I do not want to
delete the the
phrase I do not want to delete The
Mention Of Education okay and I think
that if you look down below the
education that's required to to request
Alliance and a license is pretty well
defined the question is what's it
comparable
to if it's not comparable to anything
specific in other parts of the rules I
think just education would cover it
nicely but that's and and these
components being part of what's accepted
for the
education yeah let me look back let me
see what's in the rest of the rules and
take it back to the board and come back
with something if we could get a
postponement that would be great okay
director Mor
um I think Tina do you know when the
board meets
next not off the top of my head it's got
to
be there someone has that answer behind
[Laughter]
you surpris Doo s how oplc general
counsel um the Board of Nursing is
actually meeting right now so it's going
to be at least another month before they
meet I just wanted to put that out there
okay well that's uh let's hurry up and
let you go talk to them before they uh
break
up okay an alternative would to be to do
a preliminary objection and then let the
board in the time that it needs but well
let's uh take a look at the rest of the
rule and see if there are any other
issues that need to be address before we
uh just consign it to the uh okay I I
had one other point um in attorney ree's
first comment she had noted that in
statute uh licensure by comparable
education is allowed for LPNs and it's
allowed for RNs but statute doesn't say
anything about lnas and it seems like if
they wanted to do that they should seek
statutory
change good
point I think um some of the the other
comments I had um the legislative intent
comments you're going to see throughout
the rest of the document um there are
some that we've talked about before
related to the fee so I won't spend any
time on that the other ones were because
um the rules have been expired since
March so um that's not a terribly long
time but that has been since March 22nd
of this
year so with regards to the expiration
of these rules I looked back and I went
through the rsas and anything um that
was would have been enforced is in
statute um
qualifications um exams that's all laid
out right in statute and there have been
and I also looked to see if there was
any disciplinary actions taking on
anything and there was
not oh good to
know any other comments or or
questions represent hackin Phillips um
Madam chair I'd like to move to postpone
with a waiver uh so that the oplc has a
chance to coordinate with the board on
this one
okay second second by representative
Schmidt any discussion of the of the
motion all right those in favor I
opposed all right yes please it's
disconcerting to see uh
inconsistencies all right physical
therapists okay um so
2023-the this proposal was also
postponed from the last meeting so that
the rules could be amended to accurately
reflect that the oplc is processing
licensing applications and the board has
filed an amended conditional approval
and it has addressed that concern there
are some other legislative intent
comments um at the last meeting the
committee had discussed that that some
of the rule sections have been expired
since
2021 and there's a a question again on
the collection of fees during the rules
expiration um from Rebecca's notes it
looks like um or attorney ricard's notes
it looks like that this issue was
discussed last time and so we may not
need to revisit it but I thought I would
um bring it to your attention in case
you do um also at the last meeting
Senator gray had recommended that the
board pursue alleged islative fix to
make it clear that submitting late
documentation in response to an audit
request will be considered professional
misconduct and um that's in response to
the comment on page 11 of the amended
conditional approval request um just so
you are aware there have been other
board proposals um from other boards
that have included similar language and
um it's usually been taken out um so I'm
not really clear why in this case why it
hasn't been done but um the issue was
that there's not there doesn't appear to
be direct statutory Authority um the
board does have authority to implement a
fine for professional misconduct but the
issue is whether or not failing to
submit documentation at all or either in
a timely manner whether or not that fits
the definition of professional
misconduct other than those issues there
were some questions about whether the
forms have been updated outside of the
rulemaking process we some of them have
some addition dates from 2022 and
there's no record of any filing to
update them but anyway that broadly
summarizes the issues and like I said
many of these were discussed last time
and the the main reason for postponement
was to allow the board to clarify who is
processing the um applications and
they've done that with the amended
conditional approval
request okay so first let me address the
expired roles so going back and looking
at the expired rules they are small
portions of bigger sections so although
a certain section may be expired it also
is addressed further on in in the the
totality of the
section um I take it this package
updates the entire section of rules and
not just slivers exactly yes thank you
um and then with regards to the fines
the board under um phy 40501 k a
violation of any of the rules is subject
to disciplinary action and
by providing fines for late submission
of Contin um audit materials it allows
for a few things it allows number one
that the ly knows exactly what's going
to happen if they're late with their
with their um documentation
number two it gives them the option of
yes I was late I procrastinated I didn't
do it I'm going to pay the fine or if
they feel like there's bigger issues
they can um have a hearing before the
board and have it discussed otherwise if
they violate the the rules they have to
come in for a hearing and this gives
them greater flexibility to make that
determination as to whether it's not
necessary to have a
hearing um and I do believe believe that
under um that the board does have the
ability to Levy
fines that that is correct like I said
in my opening statement they do have the
authority to Levy fines the issue was
whether or not you know failing to
submit
documentation was sufficient enough to
fall underneath professional misconduct
and that's why Senator gray was
recommending that they pursue a
legislative
fix okay uh how how often does this well
how often are are the education records
audited and how often is the
documentation late they're supposed to
be audited once a year um or at not once
a year I'm sorry at renewal so that
could be that's once every two years um
so so every so you're not really audit
you're you're basically asking them to
submit the ceu
documentation with their renewal no at
10% 10% of the like lies are audited ah
thank you that makes more
sense any other questions comments
concerns representative hiken Phillips
no okay anyone
else do we have a
motion do we know what the appropriate
motion would be I'm just trying to
figure out of which which category ises
this is it a move to approve move to
approve the the revised yes okay I move
to approve the the revised rules all
right second second by representative
Lynn any further discussion those in
favor opposed all right thank you very
much okay okay so um 2023 189 um oplc uh
practice and procedure rules the agency
has filed a conditional approval request
um that addressed some of our comments
but there are a lot that still remain um
you should have the conditional approval
request
um posted um for you to review but I'm
mostly going to be just talking about
the comments on the final proposal U
meeting packet so it would be best to
look at that um the first comment is on
page five
of the final proposal packet which is
going to be page one of the rule text
and here there's a comment that the
agency hasn't cited 310a in the rule
text or in the
appendex the sections of the statute
applying to the operations of the oplc
have been
repealed however there are other
sections of 310a that the oplc will be
relying upon when conducting hearings
based on hearings on complaints and so
those sections should be at least
referenced in the
appendex for example um The Proposal
talks about that um that the oplc will
receive complaints against lenses for
engaging in unregulated or engaging in a
regulated profession without a
license and let's say for instance
that's um you know engineering well then
um RSA 310 a25 would be applicable and
it says that such a violation is a
misdemeanor thus RSA 310 a25 will be
enforced or at least relied upon and
should be mentioned in the
appendex and um in response in an email
response um between our office and the
oplc IT stated that they've never cited
the other statutes but it is worth
noting that back in September the
committee approved a PLC interim rule
that also had this same exact issue in
which the oplc did not want to put did
not want to amend its appendex um the
committee did tell the agency to amend
the appendix during the regular rul
making to include statutory Authority
for statutory requirements that the oplc
is incorporating or relying upon to
enforce the rules or statutes regardless
of whether they are oplc statutes or the
board statutes so um our our position is
that they really do need to at least
amend the appendex to make sure it
accurately reflects what statutes they
will be enforcing anyway I I didn't know
if you want me to stop there before I
move on to the other comment I think
that's a point we want to settle before
we go
further good morning Douglas osterhout
general counsel for the oplc with me is
my um attorney who works with me Brenda
golden Housey um I think we disagree I
think what we're talking about when
we're talking about all these other
statutes listed in rule are charging
statutes and what these rules apply to
are the proceedings so the the
references that are being asked to put
in the rule are sort of those lists of
misconduct this is what happens after
the fact so the charging statutes and
the rules addressing hearings are very
different and the other thing I'd like
to point out is
that um misdemeanors are not handled by
the office we don't handle criminal
complaints that is covered by Department
of Justice we are a li a professional
licensing agency not a law enforcement
agency so those statutes don't really
apply to us as far as unlicensed
practice goes now the boards can take
action against an individual who does
unlicensed practice but they could not
find them guilty of a misdemeanor so it
is important to distinguish between the
criminal action and the action taken
against the individual
leny and we also have in plc 201102 and
B as provided in RSA 310 where our
statutory Authority comes from this
chapter shall apply to the professions
listed in RSA 310 colon 2 Roman numeral
2 we point them directly to the list
boards that this applies
to thank you so that if someone were
being um the board if the board of
Engineers were concerned about someone
performing engineering without a license
they could do various investigatory
things against the license of the person
or they could refer them to the attorney
general for prosecution for the
misdemeanor or both or both correct
okay comments
questions
concerns how Madam chair how does the
committee feel about having this
inconsistency um if we were to agree
with the
opl's um position here versus how we
ruled earlier this year sounds like in a
different matter about this
issue I have no
idea so um as we move further down I've
got a um there are a lot of legislative
intent comments and so um one thing we
were going to recommend is actually that
this item be postponed um because the
agency really need the they need more
time to go back through especially when
you get to section 207 you'll see there
that um there are comments on the pages
of 31 through 33 of the packet and here
they're attempting to address the
procedures for rulemaking for both the
boards and the oplc but the problem is
is that um the requirements aren't going
to be the same um the boards can't hold
virtual hearings they can hold remote
hearings under specific circumstances
but anyway um before I get too much into
that they're just um the oplc didn't
make any changes to that section in
response to comments and they actually
stated that um had they gotten the
comments back you know in a in a timely
manner then maybe they could have
addressed my comments or our comments so
um we really think that they need more
time to to um to address those comments
and to go through
them yes I think having a conflict
between the rul making procedures of of
a specific board and of the oplc in
general is not a good thing and I hope
that in one of the many pieces of
legislation we'll be considering this
coming year that that issues has been
addressed representative Schmidt well I
the idea of postponing to get to have
the time to do what we've just been
talking about seems eminently reasonable
and appropriate to me so I'm happy to
move uh to request um postponement NL
second okay any further comments or
questions Mr AER house you had a
comment I don't agree that there's a
conflict um first of all we did make a
change to the 207's it wasn't we didn't
address every comment specifically but
in 2071 we added a sentence um to
2071a we added the sentence the rules of
this part shall be construed and
implemented in compliance with the
requirements of RSA 91a in particular
RSA 91 A2 relative to meeting of boards
generally and RSA 91 a24 relative to
meeting of the state boards and I think
what's really interesting here is that
the statutory reference is exactly the
same they both reference RSA 91 A2 so I
don't think there's confusion
additionally the way the rules are now
passed by the jail car we don't parse
them out
between the boards and the office now
policy-wise procedurally they may be a
little bit different because the boards
and the office have different rules
governing by 91a
541a but the statute we we have to
comply with the statute as part of the
rule so I again disagree with OS
comments that this is conflicting or
it's unclear because we don't read these
rules in a vacuum we read them in
totality
and in conjunction with the statutes be
they 91a 541a 310 The Practice Act
whatever it may be so I don't I don't
see the confusion there if it's an oplc
meeting it follows the general uh 9182
statute and if it's a board meeting it
follows that exception under R meeting
rule four uh for the
boards okay it's very clear to
me director Mor um in the conditional
approval requests at the top of page two
in
2071a um the attorney a how had talked
about the new language which states in
part the rules in this part shall be
construed and implemented in compliance
with the requirements of
91a well if you look down to on the
final proposal in
20714 C4 excuse me the there a
definition of virtual hearing well I
don't see how you can construe that
definition to be in compliance with 91a
when boards cannot hold a virtual
hearing uh 91a
prohibits so I disagree that the add
added
language uh covers that
problem there's nowhere else in the rule
where a virtual healing for a board
specifically is even cont cont plated it
might be easier just to remove that
definition if that would add Clarity but
again these are the definitions lifted
from
541a the question is are the
boards holding virtual hearings they
would not be because that would be in
violation of
Statute okay represent I I really do
think and um Mike and I talked about
this that and Scott Eaton attorney Scott
Eaton as well that um PLC 207 really
does need to be split apart to clearly
address the differences between the oplc
holding rulemaking hearings versus the
requirements on the boards for ruem
hearings like um director moral said the
boards can't hold virtual hearings and
can only hold remote ones under specific
circumstances so the rules really need
to be clear about the requirements you
know what applies to what um and like I
said the agency had stated if they had
gotten the comments back in you know in
a more timely basis they could have
addressed it so I really feel like we
can give them some more time to do so
okay we we have a mo we are discussing a
motion to do so any other comments
represent just you know what just to go
back to like the first comment that was
made
um uh on with regard to PLC 20 2.06 I
mean it does seem to me that isn't that
isn't the comment that was made by the
staff well taken I mean that that
the the the the if the the statute talks
about getting um provided that any
complainant shall have the opportunity
before the settlement agreement has been
approved uh to comment on the terms of
the proposed settlement it doesn't but
you use the word consultation so that
and it seems to me that those things are
really considerably different um the
consult consultation suggest to me that
you know whoever is gonna whoever is
commenting has a right to have some
discussion consultation with the B with
the decision maker as opposed to Simply
commenting on on something so that I
mean I I guess I do think that that's a
valid
uh criticism of The Proposal if I could
that comment was addressed and I
apologize to the committee it looks like
that you do not have the conditional
approval request posted so you can't see
it but they have addressed that comment
I'm sorry sir we age I'm sorry we made
the
change okay director moral um a moment
ago attorney Reed had said that the
agency should have more time to split up
207 the reason for this in part at least
in part is it can be difficult to tell
as it is what applies to oplc and what
applies to the boards because as I was
talking about virtual hearings
departments which would include oplc can
hold virtual hearings it's boards and
commissions that cannot they have to
have a quorum present at an in-person
hearing okay so that's something that
could be clarified either by as you say
splitting up the rule into two parts or
adding a separate section defining the
differences for the boards may I propose
an alternate suggestion that we pass
these rules and we know we're going to
be opening them up again because of
legislative changes in the near future
that because I do think these are better
than the existing 200s which don't split
make that distinction between the boards
and the PLC we can function with these
because we have the statutes to rely on
in conjunction with the rule and then we
can address that down the
road okay we have a comment on to
postpone it to to incorporate some other
changes which is the the matter on the
floor is there any further discussion on
that
motion okay those in favor of
postponing I opposed all right we will
give you a chance to fix some of those
things and then we will consider
adopting them with a recommendation to
go back into Ru making thank you very
much
okay um the next item is an interim rule
um from the Board of Education it's on
school nurse lure and renewal um Ed uh
Ed uh 504
rules um these are on School nurses the
rules are implementing SB 215 from the
last session and you should have a copy
of that in the packet um the change that
was made to the law would allow well
actually requires School nurses to
complete their ba within six years of
hire the agency has filed a conditional
approval request and you should have a
copy of that it pretty much resolved the
issues we had on the initial interim
rule filing um the issues were mostly um
editorial or currently mostly editorial
but there is one comment on page three
of the conditional approval request and
it's an authority comment um this might
actually be an editorial comment too and
so if so then they really could address
all these things during regular rule
making but anyway here uh we have a
comment because the rule appears to
allow School nurses school nurse 3s um
to be licensed in another state and
practice in our state and we weren't
really sure whether that's allowable or
if the board of education has the
authority to allow it so that is in
essence what that Comon is like I said
it it could be an editorial matter here
um and if so it it can definitely be
addressed during regular R making if
so
okay put push the button again till the
red light comes on there you go my name
is Susan Blake I'm the administrator for
the Department of Education Bureau of
credentialing um and this is Julie Shay
Julie Shay administrative rules
coordinator for the Department of Ed
with regard to um page three and the
question that you had um the reasoning
behind it was to open up um to reduce
barriers to becoming a school nurse
three but um we will absolutely take out
we leave in this the New Hampshire P so
we will um limit it to people with a New
Hampshire RN
license yeah it additionally um the
thought there was that because we were
quoting the RSA and how nursing is
defined um the attorney thought that um
taking out putting New Hampshire in
there was redundant because it's implied
that by following the statute that they
would be licensed in New Hampshire that
being said if keeping in New Hampshire
there adds Clarity for the regular
person that's reading that we're okay
with that so yeah I I thought that was
the situation but I wasn't entirely sure
that's why I had it unclear SL Authority
because I I thought maybe that was the
issue yeah because I think they would
absolutely have to be licensed in New
Hampshire um but it was yeah more of a
redundancy thing but for clarity I think
it makes sense to keep it in and we're
happy to do that um all of the other
comments
um and suggestions we are fine with um
adding in the proposal and then the one
last thing I wanted to add is in C1 um
that was also editorial that should just
read as the italicized writing that says
the forms pursu in to Ed 508b and the
attestation I just didn't cross out the
rest of it
so that makes sense yeah so the the
essence is that you've worked out the
details and all the changes required
would be
editorial I mean um they could I guess
um you could decide to to do an A or
could approve conditionally approve with
them addressing these comments and their
conditional approval but yeah I I think
it's fine okay any other so moved so
moves Thank You by representative Lynn
second and second okay any further
discussion all those in favor I
opposed thank you very much thank
you all
right oh I'm watching right along the
northern border Alliance program yes
ma'am so um these are interum rules
implementing a new statute that provides
grant funding to border towns in the
North Country for uh police training the
agency has filed a conditional approval
request which El eliminated all of the
comments except for one and we um note
that that one really can be addressed
during regular Ru making um the comment
is on page five of the conditional
approval packet and here um the
highlighted paragraph does a pretty good
job of giving some basic parameters for
the commissioner's discretion but it
doesn't give like some additional detail
for how the commissional commissioner
will decide whether to award one Grant
versus another Grant so in other words
there's you know could be some more
detail there to ensure that Awards will
be uniformly applied now um while it's
not required a point system is one way
that other agencies have addressed um
discretionary decision making in the
grant or the RFP process um the manual
does not address this issue directly
because it um addresses discretionary
decision making that's more of a yes or
no kind of decision um but but here what
you've got is a pool of money and um the
agency has to decide in essence which
applicant is more deserving of that
money um for example how will it decide
um how will that decision be made if two
applicants have a very similar or almost
the same Grant proposal you know what
will be that ultimate deciding factor
weighing in favor of one over the other
but anyway all that said um we feel like
that this could certainly be addressed
during regular R making and we've often
seen where agencies aren't able to kind
of nail down all the details at the
interim rule process but are able to do
so a little bit more in the regular rule
making process so this may just need a a
sentence or two more to add some
additional Clarity but but like I said
it could be addressed during regular rle
making okay
okay good morning my name is Pam Urban
Mar
I'm the grant administrator of the
grants management unit at the department
of safety and um we worked on creation
of these rules by committee
and I've never sat before this committee
before so here I am
okay welcome glad to have you thank you
good good morning and uh I'm attorney
Dave hiltz from the Department of Safety
as well are there any questions or
comments from the
committee okay that case is there a
motion
I'll
move move by representative L seconded
by representative land all
right any further discussion comments
questions I'm looking forward to the
flushing out of the you know comment in
the rul making
process
okay so the motion is to approve the
interim
rules
those in favor I
opposed okay thank you very much thank
you right do we have any other
business a couple of quick items um last
month you heard from a member of the
Executive Vice President of the New
Hampshire Builders Association regarding
alteration of terrain rules that the
committee had approved a few months ago
uh Dees was also here uh they have been
sitting down and talking but the
Builders Association has asked that
instead of coming back this month uh
that they come back next month and they
hope to have uh more for the committee
yes I also heard from the builders and
they did in fact convince Dees that
there was an issue with certain portions
of the rule and they are working to
solve it so I'll be delighted to wait a
month to find out what they're doing
the the other item was just to note that
we are working on the calendar of
meetings for next year and we'll bring
that uh forward at the next meeting for
your approval okay any other uh there's
no other business we don't need to have
a continued meeting I I I believe okay
we will not have one
and
excuse me were were trying to make
public comment on one of these
rules
Sor Cheryl des's assistant Revenue
Council of Department of Revenue
Administration yes I guess it's not very
sensitive um Cheryl de is assistant
Revenue council at the Department of
Revenue Administration I'm going to be
um helping Ken Wang with rule making
going forward and I was here for the
tobacco rules but I'm learning now that
they're on the consent calendar so I sat
here just to learn which is wonderful
but thank you okay well I hope it was uh
in
informative yes
we
right in that case we are adjourned
thank you very
all